this is Hassan Hassan is 23 years old he
is in love with a girl called ISIL
he wants to marry her so that's why he
makes a draw every night asking Allah to
grant his dua because he really really
wants to marry her
making dois and it's being answered is
much like knocking on a closed door
waiting for it to be opened only allah
subhana wa ta'ala knows what is best for
us and when it is best for us if you
have performed this Tahara and it is not
going your way then behind that door may
be destruction
on this scenario has admitted Sahara and
he asked Allah for guidance and he
knocked on the door waiting to be
answered but he accepted his cutter and
understood that they may be destruction
behind the door and he left
on this scenario Hasan made it walk and
he was persistent on his dwarf he was
asking and asking Allah but just when
his dawah was about to be accepted he
gave up on his door and left
on this scenario Hasan made the Sahara
and even though Allah gave him science
and that it is not meant for him and
it's not good for him he persisted he
persisted
we wanted that blood to be accepted
let's see what happens
so Angela
but I shadowed by
lady the high-level feed the pop
assalamu aleikum wa rahmatullah wa
better care to brothers and sisters
before i star when a please Allah want
Allah the most merciful the most just
all praises and glory belongs to him and
everything that we do
it may be YouTube Facebook whatever it
may be it's all with his permission and
all glory and praise belong to him now
brothers and sisters as you saw yourself
from the different scenarios that we had
from the moment this individual who
wanted to make it war and how
destruction was waiting and we've made
this narrow way if unlost want allah
allowed that door died he went it's so
bad but it was bad for him for it to
continue what kind of destruction he
would have been left with then we had a
scenario of the same person making a
draw and trying his best carrying on the
doís but then acknowledging that there's
something of the color of allah things
are not going right then obviously that
means that you know maybe you know Allah
so Allah doesn't want it to happen and
he accepts the color of Allah and he
says Allah knows best and leaves it and
he goes about his business and obviously
this changes with different matters of
course and also lastly we had a we had a
scene where he's asking for his door
he's banging on that door but at the
last minute when he's been making that
dwarf for constantly for years and
months and he's banging on that door and
when he's just about to be answered he
gives up and he says you know what I
give up and walks off and that's when it
was just about it his door to be
answered now there is a narration or of
a barrera from the Prophet Muhammad
sallallahu wasallam where he says every
supplication every doer of a believer is
answered except those who say I made war
to my rub but my door hasn't been
answered that door would not be accepted
because you're giving up your giving and
you've given up hope in Oliphant allah
so abu huraira narrated that from the
first mr. abu salem sallalaho aleyh we
sell them so we know from that now
brothers and sisters what we need to
understand is this sometimes we face
you to understand that when we make a
door when we want something so bad and
when I guess it's gotta be that instead
of making it water alas you know Allah
if it's good for me whatever is best for
me whatever is best in this life in the
hereafter or Allah gives me that even if
it's the matter of you want to marry
somebody the matter of going somewhere
studying whatever it may be instead of
saying oh Allah let this happen say oh
Allah give me what's best
this is best for me all I let it happen
but many times we do not do this what do
we do we want something that's specific
yo that specific guy it has to be him
I want I want to marry him it's gotta be
him he's my happiness because in our
head were thinking that is our happiness
what what do we do
we chase that we chase it yet do we not
understand that when that Y is not being
accepted when that dois is not being
accepted brothers and sisters we start
to think to ourselves have I done a sin
am i doing something wrong
oh yeah I lost me maybe I was punishing
me you know we start to delude ourselves
with these stuff because we have no
patience and we need to have a patient I
also want Allah says those who are
patient their reward is with Allah in
the Quran Allah Allah says this now we
need to understand this job persist in
it you what anytime says you're
persisting on this dwarf now you need to
understand something
Allah is not punishing him Allah may not
do anything to anything to do with your
sin Allah so Allah is actually his mercy
he's showing his mercy when that DeWyze
not being answered let's say that does
not mean and it's not good for you but
what do you do you start to rebel you
start banging on that door you like
please Allah accept my door accept my
door when Alice want Allah doesn't allow
that to are to come to me except to
straight away maybe later on you start
to rebel
now if Alice wants her to open that door
for you and said you know what there you
go you're persisting on it so much and
destruction hits you just as we saw
that's just as we showed you on the
video then what you're gonna do you're
gonna complete emergency oh Allah why
did you allow it to happen so you need
to understand that with your own self as
human beings we will never be happy if
he's not accepted if we're not patient
if it's not accepted which you do not
know if it's not been accepted
because we believe every du'a of the
believer which is not Haram is the
accepted if not in this life in the
hereafter so we and know that we
acknowledge that even Alice want Allah
says in the Quran I respond to the
caller who calls upon me now this Alice
want to let's say I call upon that one
who wears the hijab and the niqab who
has the beard and the phobe no he said I
respond to the caller atheist whoever
you are whoever you are non Muslim
atheist he will respond and obviously if
is it a person who is a believer
obviously it shall always want Allah
will answer quicker but you need to
understand Alice wants Allah will answer
so we need to understand it you need to
have a balance and be patient when
you've asked for something persist on it
if you want if you want it to really
happen you need to persist on it and ask
for it and keep asking for it so we
persist we persist on the doís and we're
just fighting it and we want it we want
to be banging on that door but what
little do you know that Alice want Allah
has is bestowed his mercy on you because
there is destruction behind that door
maybe not not that specific time so we
need to learn to be patient and take a
step back and sometimes say you know
what's the color of Allah maybe there's
something bad that's going to happen
also guys as we know Alice want Allah
says I am - my slave how he or she
thinks of me so however you think all of
us want Allah that's how we will be
towards his towards a believer so
brothers and sisters when making a drop
be persistent put your trust in Allah
don't ever think you know after asking
for one month two month one year two
year I give up no never ever because the
moment you do that as we as we saw on
the clip that just about when your
daughter answered you say I give up then
what's the point
so also you need to understand be
persistent so we need to it's the harder
you're putting your trust and you leave
in all the matters in the hand of Allah
so Allah
now once you have done this if you start
your you start pursuing that whether
you've made whoever is an individual a
holiday a work college whatever it may
be when you see bad signs and it's not
going the way you want it don't push on
it because the sign is the other
sponsors telling you it's no good for
you if you carry on
carry on your way to destruction so
that's why we have Esther Hana we do it
with taught trust in Allah when we see
signs that it's not going to happen
I'll ask you to leave it at that so
brothers and sisters that's about it for
me in showing you guys have benefited
share the video with sha Allah move your
friends if you have friends who are
going through its difficulty where they
dislike all my doors are not being
answered share this video a lot
inshaallah with the permission of Allah
the video will benefit them also
brothers and sisters don't forget as you
know we work with brother Imran his goal
finally is gonna be at the end of the
video please donate because as you know
and little works goes into this as a bit
from me
you